[Musique]
la mairesse de montréal promettait en
campagne de rembourser la taxe de
bienvenue aux familles ayant au moins un
enfant qui font l'acquisition de leur
première propriété en tant que famille à
montréal jusqu'à concurrence de 5000 $
mais dans son premier budget n'en est
pas question
à l'exception de 21 millions prévus pour
aider les familles à se loger
on est en train de confiner le programme
alors quand on va être prêt à dévoiler
on va le faire
la taxe de bienvenue les droits de
mutation immobilière semble être leur
pour ester elle va rapporter 184
millions de dollars montréal en 2008
plus de 500 millions dans toutes les
municipalités au québec
elle provient d'une loi québécoise
instauré en 1976 puis a été rendue
obligatoire en 1992 et on s'entend que
le coût d'une maison de l'époque n'a
plus rien à voir avec celui
d'aujourd'hui
en fait ça triplé et la taxe augmente
par tranche de prix de la valeur
foncière d'une propriété alors supposons
qu'une maison valère en 1992 cent mille
dollars
vous deviez débourser 750 dollars
aujourd'hui cette même maison vaut 300
mille dollars
la taxe de bienvenue et de 3000 $ ah oui
et autres signes qui ne va pas
disparaître de sitôt
le gouvernement libéral a tout récemment
permis aux municipalités sauf montréal
d'augmenter le taux de la taxe jusqu'à
3% bienvenus qu'ils disent et
contrairement à ce que dit la légende
urbaine
l'expression taxe de bienvenue n'ont
aucun lien avec l'ancien ministre
libéral jean bienvenu serait plutôt un
calque de l'anglais de la wacom taxes
[Musique]